[Música]
todo listo en Reino Unido para el
funeral de estado de la Reina Isabel
segunda cientos de integrantes de la
realeza y líderes mundiales se reúnen
para darle el último adiós a la monarca
al tiempo que miles de británicos han
llevado homenajes Y esperan A las
afueras del castillo de Windsor el fe
retrocera enterrado en la capilla de San
Jorge
Puerto Rico continúa sin electricidad en
toda la isla tras el impacto del huracán
Fiona que además ha causado graves
inundaciones deslizamientos y destrozos
materiales también hay alerta en
República Dominicana Al otro lado del
mundo el tifón dan adulto con tierra en
la isla japonesa de donde hay miles de
evacuados y unas 300.000 viviendas sin
electricidad
el gobierno colombiano anunció una
reunión exploratoria con integrantes de
las disidencias de la antigua guerrilla
de las FARC El Ejecutivo de Gustavo
Petro Indicó que el encuentro se produjo
para valorar un posible inicio de
diálogos con estos grupos tenemos
análisis
en France 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en Reino Unido
donde todo está listo para el funeral de
estado de la Reina Isabel segunda en el
décimo día después del de su
fallecimientos de integrantes de la
realeza y dignatarios mundiales se
reúnen en la abadía de Westminster para
despedirla se trata del mayor operativo
de seguridad que haya vivido el país y
un evento que ha movilizado a cientos de
miles de personas tras los oficios se
dará en Tierra al féretro de la monarca
en la capilla de San Jorge junto a su
esposo el príncipe Felipe sus padres y
su hermana veamos más detalles en el
informe
es el primer funeral de estado británico
desde el homenaje a Winston Churchill en
1965 la ceremonia cuenta con una larga
lista de líderes signatarios mundiales
que acudirán a la abadía de Westminster
para presentar sus respetos el
presidente joeyden asistirá junto a la
primera damaiden habló de su admiración
por la difunta monarca mientras firmaba
el libro de condolencias era igual en
persona que en su imagen decente
honorable y todo dispuesta al servicio
el presidente francés Emmanuel macco
también estará allí con su esposa buey
hit para presentar sus respetos a la que
macon considera como la reina eterna los
países de la commonwealth estarán
representados por el Premier canadiense
Justin trudea el australiano Anthony
albanisi y La neozelandesa yacina arden
el Primer Ministro jamaiquino Andrew
holdness y el líder de las Bahamas
phillip Davis por América Latina destaca
la visita del presidente de Brasil Jair
bolsonaro la realeza británica no invitó
a algunos jefes de latinoamericanos a
los que considera dictadores como el
nicaragüense Daniel Ortega dos
invitaciones han causado controversia
China y Arabia Saudita países que han
sido muy criticados por su historial de
Derechos Humanos
Estará presente pero china estará
representada por su vicepresidente un
chichán por el lado Saudita no se espera
que el príncipe heredero Mohamed
binsalman asista la monarquía árabe
estará representada por el príncipe
Turkey Bean Alfa y sal Rusia y belarús
hacen parte del pequeño grupo de
Naciones sin representantes invitados
debido al actual invasión de Ucrania
Vladimir Putin tiene actualmente una
prohibición de viajar que le impide
visitar el Reino Unido y dijo que no
asistirá a las honras fúnebres la
portavoz del Ministerio de asuntos
exteriores de Rusia María sajaroa
calificó como profundamente inmoral la
decisión británica de no invitar a
ningún delegado ruso
la ceremonia tendrá lugar en la abadía
de Westminster este lunes a partir de
las 11 de la mañana Se espera que
asistan más de 2.000 personas este será
el primer funeral de un monarca
totalmente televisado
cambiamos de tema Puerto Rico continúa
sin servicio de Electricidad tras el
impacto del huracán Fiona que dejó
destrozos materiales y deslizamientos
trastocar tierra en la costa
suroccidental Con vientos máximos
sostenidos de 140 kilómetros por hora
las autoridades informaron que tomará
días restablecer las conexiones
eléctricas el presidente joeyden aprobó
la declaración de emergencia para
proporcionar medidas de protección
República Dominicana se prepara para el
posible impacto más temprano conversamos
con Ángel Crespo antiguo jefe del cuerpo
de bomberos y manejo de emergencias de
Puerto Rico y esto nos dijo el sistema
eléctrico de Puerto Rico es una de las
cosas más lastimadas que tiene nuestra
infraestructura no sólo por su
longevidad sino bien al dicho por el
impacto del huracán María se ha asignado
una un presupuesto grandísimo que
históricamente nunca Estados Unidos
había llevado a cabo un desembolso como
ese para la reparación de lo que
conocemos acá como el grid eléctrico
algo pues todavía todo esos desembolsos
toma mucha planificación siempre hay
temas burocráticos Así que es uno de los
temas más importantes Unidos a la
erosión costera que precisamente se
acercó no solamente por el calentamiento
global y el aumento en el nivel del mar
sino por la marejada ciclónica de María
Así que hay muchas comunidades
vulnerables y uno de los riesgos mayores
precisamente son ese tipo de comunidades
que están en zonas inundables y
continuamos con fenómenos climáticos
porque el tifón dando ha dejado
alrededor de 300.000 viviendas sin
electricidad en su paso por la isla de
kyushu en el suroeste de Japón además de
dejar precipitaciones récord y varios
Ríos a punto de desbordarse el más
reciente reporte de las autoridades
indicaba que el fenómeno llevaba rachas
máximas de viento de unos 180 kilómetros
por hora y avanza lentamente lo que está
provocando inundaciones importantes el
gobierno ha recomendado a los habitantes
de las zonas más afectadas que se
resguarden en sitios seguros que sean
sobre el terreno tengan una estructura
sólida y están alejados de precipicios
el clima extremo también se está
haciendo sentir en otras regiones del
mundo con un extrema sequía que azota a
China Estados Unidos y algunos países de
Europa después de uno de los veranos más
calurosos registrados en la historia
previamente Fernando Cortés Vivanco
ecologista y cofundador de tantarias
asamblea de jóvenes por la
sostenibilidad en Ecuador nos dio
detalles de estos fenómenos ahí hay
algunos impactos fundamentalmente
sociales y ecológicos en los sociales
tenemos que entender que esto afecta la
agricultura la disponibilidad del agua
potable el transporte nuestra capacidad
de generar energía entre muchos otros
aspectos de la vida cotidiana Claro sin
duda la agricultura es el campo más
afectado por la sequía a un nivel
sectorial esto a su vez contribuye al
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
y en general podemos concluir en que su
consecuente degradación ambiental limita
el acceso a la vida divina y evidentes
problemas ambientales las sequías
amenazan los ecosistemas esencialmente
los ecosistemas
afectando gravemente a la biodiversidad
y aumentando el riesgo de incendios
forestales que es una problemática
global muy importante y particularmente
en la región en otras noticias hay
expectativa en Colombia luego de que el
gobierno del presidente Gustavo Petro
anunciara que una delegación oficial se
reunió con representantes de las
disidencias de la antigua guerrilla de
las FARC El Ejecutivo explicó que el fin
del encuentro es valorar la posibilidad
de iniciar diálogos con estos grupos
como parte de su política de paz total
la reunión contó con la participación de
la misión de la ONU en Colombia y con
presencia del gobierno noruego
previamente conversamos con Daniela
garzón investigadora de la fundación paz
y Reconciliación que nos explicó Cómo
recibe el país estas exploraciones del
gobierno Petro y la política de paz
Total que También incluye diálogos con
la guerrilla dlln
yo creo que hay un buen clima de opinión
Para apoyar los intentos que el gobierno
Petro está haciendo para conseguir la
paz total sin embargo creo que hay
algunos sectores de opinión que tienen
dudas respecto de incluir a las
desidencias precisamente porque ya había
oído un proceso de paz con las Farc y es
muy reciente si bien pues el gobierno
Petro reconoce que ha habido
incumplimientos por parte del Estado
colombiano a la hora de poner en marcha
Los acuerdos pero creo que Irán
dilucidando en el camino si finalmente
Encuentran una negociación o si los
invitan al acogimiento a la justicia
recordemos que hace poco el gobierno
Petro pasó al congreso en las
modificaciones de la ley de orden
público para poder tener un manual para
poder llevar a cabo las negociaciones y
que hasta donde tenemos entendido de
parte pues del Ln Hay buenas intenciones
de sentarse nuevamente a negociar Y
aparte pues las disidencias en este caso
también están diciendo que están
dispuestos a explorar la manera de
desescalar el conflicto por supuesto
sería muy importante para Colombia
porque hoy tienen un brazo armado
importante en varias zonas del país que
está generando mucho su obra muchas
poblaciones vamos a estar Eva en la
capital de Armenia donde la presidenta
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos Nancy pelosi se reunió
con el Primer Ministro Nicole la alta
funcionaria condenó lo que calificó de
ataques fronterizos ilegales de
azerbaiyán contra este país a su vez
desde Washington el secretario de estado
Anthony blinquen instó al presidente de
azerbaiyán ilham Ali Jeff adherirse al
alto el fuego retirar las fuerzas
militares y trabajar para resolver todos
los problemas pendientes mediante
negociaciones pacíficas el gobierno
sería rechazó la postura estadounidense
y aseguró que no contribuye a la paz
regional
llegamos así al final de esta
informativo Les agradecemos su sintonía
quédense con nosotros que volvemos en
breve
[Música]